[Musique]
robert hue bonjour bonjour à trois jours
du premier tour force est de constater
qu'il n'y a pas de très social l'ampleur
des grèves et des manifestations de ces
derniers jours montre bien qu'il ya un
très fort besoin de changement une
majorité de français même s'il ne
descendent pas tous dans la rue ne se
résignent pas je voudrais tout de suite
commencer par vous faire écouter une
série de témoignages
moi ce qui m'étonne le plus c'est que ce
qu'ils nous préparent pour après les
élections c'est encore pire et nous
prépare une sélection aggravée j'ai pas
si tu as entendu parler du du rapport
laurent mais s'il était mis en oeuvre il
était mis en oeuvre
ça vous dit ça ça voudrait dire les
droits d'inscription encore plus
important ça voudrait dire une
privatisation de l'enseignement
supérieur est en fait au final ça veut
dire que pour ce conte le fric pour se
payer le luxe d'aller dans une fac comme
celle que pasqua est en train de
construire dans les hauts-de-seine
trente mille francs l'entrée quand même
où ils pourront poursuivre leurs études
ya pas de problème
puis pour les autres dans une formation
au rabais à la sortie un petit boulot
peut-être payé 80 % du smic puisque
c'était ça ce qu'on nous promettait avec
le cub3 cette société là j'en veux pas
quoi
je m'appelle bernard marquié je suis
chef de service à toulouse matabiau et
il ya 29 ans que je travaille à et
senneterre changé oui on a vu arriver
les techniques les plus modernes mais
aussi en même temps le recul du service
public la remise en cause de certains
services des fermetures de gares les
abandons de ligne et surtout pour les
cheminots qui reste le fait qu'on n'est
plus en situation de faire un autre
travail correctement
ça veut dire quoi ça fond les usagers ça
veut dire pour les usagers qu'à côté du
tgv et de certains services
informatiques performants il y à des
endroits où on roule à la même vitesse
qu'il y a trente ans il y a des sections
de lignes où on ne va toujours pas plus
vite qu'il y a trente tables il ya aussi
un manque de matériel qui peut et qui
sont entassés dans des voitures dans des
années 30 le soir pour rentrer chez eux
après la journée de travail
et pourtant on nous parle beaucoup de
modernisation voit ici à toulouse métro
automatique depuis deux jours c'est la
preuve que le progrès sur l'utiliser
bien qu on peut faire des choses
intéressantes pour tout le monde mais
malheureusement la sncf
il est confisqué sur les secteurs
rentables et il ne sert qu'à faire de
l'argent par exemple pour me serrer
ligne était gêné c'est l'europe de
maastricht est mal fait il faudrait
plutôt adapté l'europe à la pêche et non
pas l'un vers ce non pas adapter nos
moyens d'existence notre économie à une
europe
aujourd'hui par exemple les frontières
sont des passoires et permettent à des
pêcheurs aux pieds nus de venir
concurrencer avec des poissons à vil
prix
le travail et le prix de nos poissons
ici de par la politique agricole commune
instaurer les quotas laitiers on nous a
dit diminuer votre production vous aurez
un meilleur prix lorsque le marché
laitier sera assaini le marché laitier
soit disant assainies allez les prix ont
tendance même abaissé actuellement alors
c'est là que je comprends pas pourquoi
on est acceptée le gâte pour qu'on
accepte de diminuer nos exportations
profit des des américains pourquoi tout
ça et de faire disparaître un tas de
notre exploitation on à la dégradation
des conditions d'études maastricht les
services publics tous ne disent pas de
la même manière mais on sent bien que
cela ne peut plus durer
oui ce sont de fortes illustration de
cet immense besoin de changement qui
traverse le pays
ça ne peut plus continuer comme ça il ya
trop de gâchis trop de violence trop de
d'inégalités et voyez c est les gens
entassés ils veulent autre chose et ils
ont raison regarder dans ce mouvement
social actuellement dans le pays
un fort mouvement pour les salaires pour
les statuts contre la déréglementation
moi je dis à tous ces gens là vous avez
envie d'exprimer quelque chose de fort
et pour vos revendications et bien
saisissez-vous du bulletin de vote
robert hue pour en le mettant dans
l'urne le 23 avril vous ferez avancer
vos revendications
c'était effectivement un vote de
protestation
un vote de lutte en même temps certains
vous reprochent justement de ne pas
suffisamment proposés c'est injuste
c'est vrai que le vote communiste est un
vote qui porte la protestation la
révolte ça c'est vrai mais en même temps
regarder comment il dans la campagne
électorale il s'est montré comme un vote
de propositions de perspectives
pourquoi parce que quand je propose par
exemple d'augmenter de 1000 francs au
moins les salaires lorsque je propose de
réduire à 35 heures sans diminution de
salaire
la semaine hebdomadaire de travail et
bien à chaque fois je dis quelque chose
de majeur jeudi où je vais prendre
l'argent si les autres ne le font pas
moi je dis il faut réorienter l'argent
il faut plus que l'argent irait à la
finance à la boue
mais qu'il aille à l'emploi qui lie à
l'être humain c'est toute la différence
et puis regardez ce ce grand besoin
également de changement qui s'exprime
bien moi je propose qu'il y ait la
construction d'une nouvelle d'une
perspective qui permettent de ne pas se
résigner à la droite est de changer les
choses profondément dû changer les
choses à gauche oui profondément à
gauche
en axant à gauche en ancrant à gauche
alors justement sur la gauche voudrait
vous faire écouter les témoignages de
d'un député communiste qui se présente
lui-même comme critique est celui d'un
universitaire de bretagne qui dit
pourquoi ils se retrouvent aujourd'hui à
vos côtés après avoir quitté le
particulier je vais quitter par suite de
désaccords
parce que je trouvais aussi que la
démocratie interne mais n'était pas tout
à fait satisfaisante
je suis revenu après quelques essais
ailleurs toujours à gauche mais en me
disant qu'on ne rit j'irai pas à
construire un régime progressiste en
france entend dit communiste français
que par conséquent ils veulent lui
essayé de changer
plutôt que de jouer aux yeux des élus
communistes j'ai souvent pris des
positions critiques
je mesure chaque jour la tourmente
sociale dans laquelle se trouve plongé
notre pays au robert lutte contre les
méfaits de cette crise lutte contre les
méfaits de maastricht et y luttent pour
un véritable changement
ce combat doit être soutenue au premier
tour il permettra ainsi une véritable
renaissance de la gauche et robert hue
incarne bien je crois cette espérance
collective
le parti communiste a changé et robert
hue renvoie bien cette image de
changement alors le fait de vous
présenter comme le candidat d'un parti
qui a su tirer les leçons du passé a
certainement participé à créer un élan
autour de votre candidature
votre réaction à ce qu'on vient
d'entendre d'abord je remercie ces deux
personnes de soutien j'y suis sensible
naturellement le parti communiste
tu as fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
changer et va continuer d'en faire pour
être mieux communiste pour être mieux en
phase avec la société mieux au service
de notre peuple
être un parti de dialogue un parti
ouvert dynamique qui permette
effectivement d'aller vers les
changements de société et nécessaire qui
répondant bien au aux préoccupations des
citoyens des gens des jeunes en général
je crois que ces changements voyez-vous
commence à se sentir dans le pignon et
je m'en félicite
vous croyez pas qu'elle se sentirait
encore plus si vous renonciez à vous
appeler commises parce que c'est très
marqué dans la tête des gens
mais je ne souhaitons rester communiste
le communisme le mot communiste c'est un
bon mot c'est un mot qui signifie pour
moi qui s'identifient à partage qui la
communion entre les hommes à solidarité
cela n'a rien à voir avec la caricature
de ce cas ce qui a échoué à l'est et que
j'ai rejeté que nous rejetons il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui il y a la place
pour un communisme nouveau qui s'inspire
de notre héritage l'héritage du parti
communiste ne date pas de 1920
l'héritage communiste c'est le 19e
siècle c'est la commune de paris
c'est l'héritage de jaurès s'est ensuite
les grandes luttes de notre peuple front
populaire la résistance la libération
les luttes contre les guerres coloniales
c'est ça le parti communiste aujourd'hui
et c'est c'est vrai qu'il ya là un idéal
qui je crois est porteur d'autres le
porte au nom de d'autres valeurs de leur
foi mais moi je respecte ces gens là
mais il y à la voyez-vous dans le
communisme et des propositions concrètes
enfin commence effectivement à se voir
cet élan s'amplifie mais lancement de
plus en plus de plus en plus de
françaises et de français ont décidé
d'ancrer leur vote à gauche en votant
communiste cette fois ci je voudrais
vous faire là encore écouté le
témoignage de madame le maire de
nanterre est juste après celui d'un
enseignant mais cette fois que nous
avons rencontré à toulouse qui dit
pourquoi pour la première fois cette
année il votera communiste en tant que
maire comme l'est d'ailleurs robert hue
lui même
je suis très attentive
aux problèmes des gens des habitants des
familles des jeunes
je peux mesurer concrètement tous les
jours à quel point la situation
s'aggrave et je pense vraiment qu'on ne
peut pas continuer ainsi
il faut arrêter ça ça pose en grand la
question de l'utilisation de la richesse
nationale
est-ce que l'on va continuer à laisser
quelques uns s'accaparer l'essentiel des
moyens de l'argent et tous les autres
vivre dans la difficulté voire dans là
misère pour beaucoup d'entre eux je ne
pense pas je pense qu'il faut examiner
une autre répartition de cette richesse
robert hue est le seul candidat a posé
cette question en grand la question de
l'utilisation de l'argent il est le seul
candidat parmi les candidats de gauche
et pour moi c'est sans doute l'essentiel
de la raison pour laquelle je le
soutiens je soutiens fait vider et puis
robert hue je le connais bien c'est un
homme franc honnête ouvert j'ai des tas
d'autres raisons de le soutenir pour la
première fois cette année je vais
effectivement voté communiste à une
élection présidentielle
j'avais voté 1981 françois mitterrand
parce que je faisais comme partis comme
des millions de gens ne ceux qui
croyaient pouvoir changer la vie et puis
après avoir analysé un petit peu
le bilan de ses 14 années de pouvoir
j'ai été fortement déçus d'une part par
le
le poids des problèmes économiques qui
se sont aggravées avec le chômage
l'exclusion et la précarité et d'autre
part aussi pour une question morale qui
m'a fait quitter vers le parti
socialiste à laquelle j'ai adhéré et qui
était la guerre du golfe j'ai toujours
condamné la guerre du golfe et je me
retrouve dans un grand nombre de
propositions de robert hue bon pour moi
la plus importante étant enseignant
c'est celle qui consiste à enlever
l'argent consacré au surarmement à la
loi de programmation militaire qui est
énorme pour le consacrer à l'éducation
nationale c'est à dire que robert hue
voix l'éducation nationale comme un
investissement
ce qui me séduit tout particulièrement
alors que l'exode candidat particulier
de droite voit le déclin social quand
même coup une charge les français sont
en effet très nombreux à souhaiter que
la gauche soit fidèle à elle même ce
qu'elle doit être
je crois que une progression du parti
communiste le 23 avril va conforter
cette volonté que les valeurs de gauche
soit respecté que qu'une nouvelle puisse
être envisagée construite avec les
citoyens eux-mêmes pour une perspective
politique progressiste dans ce pays il
ya donc pas besoin d'être communiste
qu'on veut t revers une 23 avril
non il y avait beaucoup de communes qui
vont voter au bureau mais il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas
communiste et qui aime se serviront du
vote communiste pour exprimer leur
protestation leur volonté de
propositions salariales de propositions
de changement de perspective et je
respecterai leur point de vue je ne
serai pas propriétaire de ce qu'ils
auront mis dans leurs votes
moi je mettrais ce vote au service de
notre peuple tout laisse à penser que la
gauche sera bien présente au second tour
c'est ce que la gauche sera présente au
second tour
d'abord parce que la droite a choisi son
son candidat c'est chirac et balladur va
être éliminé la gauche représente la
question donc essentiel c'est le poids
que représentera à la fois la composante
communiste parce que on voit bien que la
droite est en situation de d'être
peut-être élu à la présidence de
république
il faudra bien résisté après il faudra
bien se battre il faudra bien changer
les choses on aura besoin d'un parti
communiste plus fort et plus influents
et ça peut se faire le 23 avril cette
année en très important qui peut se
produire
[Musique]
mais je pense que le plus important
aujourd'hui c'est d'être entendu et
surtout comprend compris parce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui beaucoup de
candidats écoute sans vraiment
comprendre
robert hue bonjour bonjour vous ne
pensez pas de sentiment de ne pas être
entendus les citoyennes et des citoyens
l'ont encore plus lors de cette élection
présidentielle si ça se comprend depuis
le début on explique aux français qu'on
leur demande aux rien sauf à choisir
entre deux candidats désignés en avance
et donc incompréhensible dans ces
conditions que google soit dans une
situation de désintérêt par rapport à
l'élection ou soit dans la recherche
d'un vote de refus mais je veux le dire
clairement il y as danger car les choix
qui vont être faits après cette élection
vont concerner directement la vie de
chacune et de chacun
qu'est ce qui peut peser sur ses choix
s'abstenir se limiter à protester ou
bien faire en sorte que ceux qui
marquent cette élection ce soit le refus
de la politique de la droite et du grand
patronat
ce soit le rejet de l'extrême droite ce
soit l'exigence que la gauche mène
demain une politique plus à gauche pour
faire mieux
des mesures d'urgence contre le chômage
la précarité les injustices et
discriminations de toutes sortes des
réformes pour se dégager de la
domination de l'argent roi
pour que la france travaille à
transformer l'europe et le monde
ce ne sont pas des mots c'est ce que la
gauche peut faire demain 2 dont nous la
force par le vote du 21 avril de
l'exiger et cette fois d'être entendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]